so javi and I talk to each other it's
really a no bro ski Bush what's up
what's up uterus oh good mom you know
what smart field Johnson Cicero
what's up people I'm javi Kuwait's
brother and I'm Jab eco-friendly he's
not friends in the actual jab eco I know
he scares me and so there's this video
that came out from Jeb eco a desi date
Asus China hopefully I'm saying her name
right that's why he has his channel and
we have ours my brother recommended I
checked this out
apparently he's dating some very famous
Indian actress huh hey man got a move on
up in the world well she's gonna feel
like she landed the wrong brother when
she sees this video look out shots taken
maybe she'll react to this video yeah
and then you know that'll start a whole
inception and then eventually you guys
would get married girlfriend will kill
me ruin your relationship yeah then I'll
be a major trouble and I won't be
welcome back here for encouraging the
job he found in the Santa Monica waters
carrying concrete around my ankles I've
been watching The Sopranos let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
hi you sound on hi
Jesus Wow hi hi hi you you look great
thank you you look nice too very dressed
up
are you I think we put an interview
right after this yeah the local male
strip club is looking for men who can
dance like they're having convulsions
and I'm a perfect fit no no I was making
a joke
I love in a [ __ ] it sure much bigger
news than Priyanka and Nick Jonas make
headlines no you look great
I'll just take my clothes off I mean you
do yeah you can keep it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I really like the lights and you stay up
forever all the videos will have they're
not actually mine Dara charas oh yeah
you know I was I was a bum lost you are
you beating leshawna
no no why would you why would you no no
no no if I was dating her no I would
never ever ever sleep
I would totally kuzey I couldn't I
Michael
waved myself Trader Joe's that's the
store gates
so I made myself a thing yeah I hope
that's okay that's okay yeah having Jay
anyway well you know you're gonna eat I
can't if you're not eating you know what
great that's good be okay this is
embarrassing burning your mouth no this
the good day it's a king in India you
know if you dip it for too long and the
bottom you know it gets quiet man it's
gonna be there at the quarantine is your
quarantine man boring no not at all I'm
having a lot of fun it's been a
productive actually I am dubbing for
this new animated series for Netflix
India I memorize
my lines of code are active season two
and there's this group that I pitch to
unwrap wait hold on
on on on rock D on rug Conor kasha yeah
yeah Wow marry her oh yeah yeah super
busy I'm so damn busy okay I'm like I
haven't slept in three four weeks I'm so
busy no nothing like nothing like that
like that I've been live streaming on
YouTube oh why go on YouTube I go live
and then we straight which key is it
yeah how'd you know that you watched it
no he keeps getting this filthy turkey
knee yeah non-veg teen babe do you win
accidents forget there's no turkeys in
that game it's thickened I mean she
played and she sucks
thank you nowhere near as bad as me I'm
not I'm not much better
truth be told
yep and that's what keeps you busy
yep that's really it's really I'm
feeling pissed yeah I mean people
watching me fail miserably we all have a
good laugh I know it's crazy lost yeah
yeah you snack the YV door okay huh
sorry I also mess who and do the dishes
okay with me mister friend zones I like
your dress
I'll get you some Real Deals do you know
something me though
so TK means okay yeah I know I know that
I also is your mom listening yeah I also
know what motto choke means you can go
whatever you want you can tell them what
biscuit if it makes you happy
whatever works for you
[Music]
well me you should be if she makes noise
you can just make that part of it and
like I'm sorry yeah you know I go live
and it was streaming roll
[Laughter]
hi hold on I'm over tunnel overdoing the
[ __ ] out of this hole Hannes next
Olivier
I'm trying too deep with me mr.
Renaissance
okay but don't smile you're a mean mom
don't smile at me yeah you know you
don't like me I'm trouble your look is
so perfect
your look is so perfect now you
candidate pick me mr. pencils can we do
that again just a reaction channel
reacts dealing subscribing doesn't do
any work
he shot that on his webcam in iMovie all
right subscribe terrible
obviously just kidding that was really
funny I'm used to seeing him do like
with the acting stuff going for the more
serious things
I thought his comedy was very natural
like his uncomfortable behavior I was
really believing it was like the office
esque uncomfortable humor
I thought Jabba did a really great job
I'm used to seeing him do more like the
serious work or trying to do something
with more of the heavier dramatic side
other than like some ad sketch but to do
a full-on sketch like this I was very
natural I was able to just stop seeing
you know my brother that I'm so used to
seeing yeah he's nothing like this in
real life that's the funny part he's
sleeping with all the woman Oh
every woman you've ever seen every guest
one in a row that's why he's not allowed
over here the amount of I don't even
want to make that joke about him and my
girl know about him and you oh no hi - I
have seen him get uncomfortable if he
says some comment and my girlfriend
calls him out on you know a tad bit
flustered and how to respond to
something these moments from here on out
this is my favorite kind of humor in a
lot of ways that is very uncomfortable
awkward sorta like Parks and Rec the
office kind of humor yeah where it's
very natural and I'm sorry I mean this
is actress who's famous actress she's
like super game for this super charming
and yes super super funny
I'm wonder if she was really into Jabby
you know this is about surprise very
very natural and I like that he kept in
the Edit some of those pauses for those
little looks yeah forth like because
this if it is a desi date you know like
dates especially first dates were full
of those little awkward moments of like
are they yeah a little bit or is this
awkward and I thought it really caught
though is really nice I loved how it was
like a clever commentary on social
status when a woman is much more
successful than the man and what that
does to the male ego oh yeah in a time
like this shabby was totally status 3 in
this video he really I was one was a
sauce and then her mom was status as
status one was mom yeah
okay to date someone who's more
successful than yourself and I love how
that was a big part of the message here
because I mean she super famous wildly
successful and then he reactor
livestreamer and you know he got he had
a chance to really do a lot of
introspection and evaluate just how this
woman has you know yourself with people
who are where you want to be ya gotta
take jabs at himself like the comment
was saying
jabs jabs cohan's Kawai some jabs Kawai
but the comments you know the crap that
he gets on those live students for not
being good at that video game making fun
of that she's talking with her mom
off-camera that the one with all the
girlfriends yeah it's really funny
self-aware moment i honestly thought
like she was great as expected to me you
expect her to be great because she's
really successful in her career but
Jabby i've never seen this side of him
in a full-on sketch before mine is so
real and i loved it i was great i
thought he was really really great i was
wonderful okay you brought the charm and
now all I want is a sketch where you're
both being awkward together yeah doing
the awkward comedy and then you know
somebody else has the the power position
cuz I want to see what happens when you
know you both cuz you you're good at
that flavor and I mean he's just got
some just for the Hortis with a hidden
camera in real life alone in a room and
you'll get it next Abbie's birthday he
doesn't have anything like that because
he's an extremely common me tool and
this kind of sketch to to do with a
famous livestreamer yeah he's great and
jokes about him and Achara dating - I
thought were really funny when the whole
time I was watching like it's jar
recording isn't it make you fun out of
that with what the commentators say and
everything
I thought this is really rich and this
is like a common sketch format that I'm
seeing on you mean we even did one for
the venom 2 trailer yeah with warm from
cosmic wonder where we had him Skype in
and we recorded that as part of the
sketch and then this is another version
that with a much higher quality on his
head that really clear Christian well
and it I got the sense was like a
guideline where this would go maybe not
a full-on script yeah a little improv
yeah which is hard
oh and it's not fully scripted so hard
to keep yourself on track as the acting
director it's bad especially for in his
situation where you're acting you're
directing the performance you have to be
like in the moment yeah but you're also
kind of thinking about the Edit when ya
doing this thing you know especially if
you're gonna be the one doing you're
probably like well I don't want to get
myself too much footage to work with
screw-ups or whatever yeah yeah this is
cool this better than just some
interview yeah and then the outtakes
oh really made me think that she was in
him mmm yeah I mean there was a lot of
fun there was a lot of playfulness there
was a lot of way to go bro the time and
I talked to each other way to go bro sit
bruh yeah smash and bra smashing like
that bra that's how we talk I I can
attest to that yeah all this it's a
character one character Greg Alba is a
whole other game he'll never see the
real yes but jabbing I talk alright guys
well subscribe to Jabby Kawai if you
haven't done so already at the time
we're uploading this you probably found
us through [ __ ] eco way so thanks for
being here Co a family love the Kauai
family
they were always nice to me after a few
months separation from the first time
they met they really have embraced me so
I appreciate that
hey subscribe to us if you had done so
already click that notification bell and
like this video that why don't we ever
say that we should like this video and
patreon
Rosa para Rosa my dear you hit us up on
patreon
recently I know out of all the videos we
uploaded this month this is the least
likely you're gonna watch it don't worry
I'm gonna be stun you cinema and this
counts but Rosa you have been the Lady
Stark of our channel for quite some time
heard you had a great Mother's Day heard
that from you directly so I know it was
a good Mother's Day I even starting up a
lot of ventures with your podcast and
such you're part of the Film Critics
Association now we've ever gotten
we were talking recently about us having
like a Skype session so we could have
our own desi date as well but knowing
how that would go you'd want me to leave
the room so you could be alone with John
if you were one of the guys at our
patreon you'd want John to leave but
keep me around because John and I get it
I get it
well you have to run the camera though I
know yeah I know why do I always there
for all your dates
even before corns you know I need your
support
I'm trying John especially with Rosa
Rosa thank you for showing extra support
to us during this time I've said of
countless times and I really mean it
every single time and the feeling only
gets deeper for me you are one of the
most important people to us at our
patreon page and just in life right now
so how do your children for us keep on
biting that cinema fight and thank you
for all the hard work you're doing in
the hospital at the same time we're
suing your film passion you really are
an inspiration my dear keep being the
lady start that we've always thought you
to be